TODAY, THE DOW GAINED 197, THE
S&P 500 WAS UP 25, THE NASDAQ
FINISHED AHEAD 65 TODAY.
YOU CANNOT WATCH MOVIES OR
TELEVISION THESE DAYS WITHOUT
SEEING STORIES ABOUT ROBOTS OR
OTHER MACHINES TAKING OVER THE
WORLD.
THAT IS SCIENCE FICTION, AT
LEAST SO FAR.
OTHER PEOPLE HAVE SERIOUS
REAL-WORLD CONCERNS ABOUT
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE.
TONIGHT CORRESPONDENT
GILLIAN TURNER SHOWS US THE
DEBATE ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY.
>> THE WORLD IS BECOMING A
COMPUTER.
COMPUTING IS GETTING EMBEDDED IN
EVERY PERSON, PLACE, AND THING.
>> ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE KNOWN
AS AI IS THE EMERGING TECHNOLOGY
THAT WILL BE THE FUTURE OF
EXISTENCE, SCIENTISTS ARE
PREDICTING INNOVATION WILL NOT
ALWAYS BE THE SOLE DOMAIN OF
HUMAN BEINGS.
>> MY NAME IS PEPPER.
>> DEVICES SPURRED BY AI ARE
ALREADY AVAILABLE.
NEW USES DISCOVERED ON A DAILY
BASIS.
TO THE LATEST DEVELOPMENT COMES
FROM GOOGLE THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE
SMARTPHONES TO MAKE APPOINTMENTS
ON THEIR BEHALF USING A
REALISTIC SOUNDING DIGITAL
VOICE.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING BETWEEN
10:00 A.M. AND 12:00 P.M.?
>> WE HAVE A 10:00.
>> 10:00 A.M. IS FINE.
>> THEY ARE COMING SO FAST AND
FURIOUS THAT THEY GOT THE
ATTENTION OF PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO
IS LAUNCHING A NEW PUSH TO MAKE
SURE THAT COMPANIES USE THE
TECHNOLOGY RESPONSIBLY AND
PROTECT TO THE CONSUMERS.
TO THE WHITE HOUSE OFFICE OF
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY POLICY
HOSTED THE SUMMIT ON AI,
BRINGING TOGETHER TECH GIANTS
INCLUDING AMAZON, FACEBOOK,
GOOGLE, INTEL, AND 34 OTHER U.S.
COMPANIES.
IT FOCUSED ON AI'S ROLE IN FIVE
KEY U.S. SECTORS, FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE, ENERGY AND
MANUFACTURING, FINANCIAL
SERVICES, HEALTH CARE, AND
TRANSPORTATION AND LOGISTICS.
TODAY THE COMMERCIAL USE OF AI
IS UNREGULATED.
BUT LAWMAKERS ARE LOOKING AT
CONCERNS OF PRIVACY.
>> THE RACE TO PRODUCE A
PREDICTABLE RESULT IS ONLY
INCREASING WITH SMART ASSISTED
US LIKE ALEXA AND SIRI IN YOUR
POCKET AND LISTENING AT HOME TO
YOUR NEXT COMMAND.
>> THEY HAVE ALSO PURSUED
FEDERAL DOLLARS FOR ADVANCING
THEIR MOTIVATION.
MEANING THAT CONGRESS WILL HAVE
A LARGE ROLE TO PLAY IN AI GOING
FORWARD.
BUT IT IS NOT JUST PRIVATE
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE INTERESTED
IN USING MORE AI ON THE
ALSO DEVELOPING NEW TECHNOLOGY
LIKE THESE PATROL ROBOTS WHO
SERVE AS THE EYES AND EARS FOR
U.S. TROOPS ON THE GROUND.
NATIONAL SECURITY EXPERTS ARE
RINGING ALARM BELLS ABOUT THE
THREAT OF AI CYBER ATTACKS.
DIGITAL TOOLS WHERE ENEMIES CAN
ATTACK THE CYBER SYSTEMS.
THEY SAY THAT AMERICAN